♪ (AMBIENT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER: About 9:30,
I was by myself on the beach.
There was two people
in the water already.
I heard screaming.
And I saw the blood.
SPEAKER 2: It seemed like
more and more sharks
were arriving at Cape Cod
each year,
but not until
the poor boy was killed
did it really seem like, okay,
now they're here.
SPEAKER 3:
It's never quite been the same
since the fatal attack.
It did cause a rift
in the community.
This was a beautiful, young man
who lost his life
because we've been sitting,
doing nothing.
SPEAKER 2: Violence
can intersect any moment,
but one wouldn't have thought
on a sunny afternoon
off the coast of New England,
a shadow was waiting.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER 4:
It's easy to get caught up
in the Jaws angle to things...
It was like this big around!
SPEAKER 4: ...and take our eye
off the bigger picture.
The research we're doing
is really
to learn more
about these animals,
so that we can prevent
a bad interaction with a shark.
-Got him.
-Yeah!
SPEAKER 5: Sharks,
they're attracted by the seals,
and there are a lot of seals.
SPEAKER 6: Because of that
Marine Mammal Protection Act,
you can't touch 'em,
you can't look at 'em.
You can't even yell at 'em
as you go past 'em.
SPEAKER 7:
But there's something else
going on down there.
The waters warm,
so everything's marching north.
Human activities
have imbalanced the ecosystem.
SPEAKER 8:
We have a problem here,
ladies and gentlemen,
and the problem is man-made.
SPEAKER 2: We like to think
that our lives are orderly,
but we don't find cooperation
from the natural world.
-Did you see that? A fin.
-(WHISTLE BLOWS)
SPEAKER 3: Some of these people
are acting like
the ocean's
their little playground.
Nah, it doesn't work that way.
Went right in the damn
swimming area.
Marine balance equation means
humans are part of the equation.
SPEAKER 2: Finding that balance
is not easy.
SPEAKER 3:
Humankind must learn humility
in the face of nature.